What turns an undead into a hollow?
Is it a passing centuries in a neverending life?
The experience of dying hundreds of times?
Or is it those things coupled with a loss of hope?
Firelink is often the last place the heroes visit before they hollow.
It's the gateway to many dangerous places.
Most undead in Lordran have a purpose that they strive towards, before hollowing.
However, there is one who is content to wait until his sanity slips away.
The apathy of this man is kept within Firelink Shrine,
where he simply watches.
Heroes come and go, some never return
and he remains.
At least nothing will bother him once he goes hollow.
"Oh, did you see him?
Big Hat Logan,
the legendary sorcerer,
in the flesh!
This place is simply mad!
Legendary heroes popping up left and right...
They're making me feel quite inadequate, to be honest."
"Oh, have you seen that terribly morose lass?
The Fire Keeper.
She's stuck keeping that bonfire lit. Sad, really.
She's mute and bound to this forsaken place."
"How did that silly sorcerer's apprentice end up?
You know, the one always prattling on about Master Logan.
He left for the Undead Burg, but never came back.
Servers him right.
If even Old Big Hat can't make it out there...
...what chance does he have?
I hope he enjoys his new life as a hollow."
"How did that raggedy old chum end up?
You know, the one who idolized some godmother of pyromancy.
He left for Blighttown,
but never came back."
"Did you hear about the maiden?
The virtuous lass came back alone, and in absolute tatters…
Did her followers die, or was she abandoned?
Who knows...
But I suppose we've heard the last from "M'lady"."
"Did you ring the second bell?"
"That is incredible, I must say…
But now we have a new problem.
It's noisy, it snores, and its breath is lethal…
And I was really beginning to like it here.
Sigh… Maybe it's time I do something about it…"
"Well,
what are you going to do?
I've already decided.
I don't really care.
I am simply...
...crestfallen."